‏v
[Silence]
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمد رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
النا الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله السلام
عل ان شاء
الله
[Silence]
‏t سفد
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
وما ابرئ نفسي ان النفس
لاماره
بالسوء الا ما رحم ربي ان ربي غفور
رحيم وقال الملك ائتوني به استخلصه لنفسي
فلما كلمه قال انك اليوم لدينا مكين
امين قال اجعلني على
خزائن الارض اني حفيظ عليم وكذلك مكنا
ليوسف يتبوا في
الارض وكذلك بوانا ليوسف في الارض يتبوا
منها حيث
يشاء نصيب برحمتنا من
نشاء وكذلك بوانا وكذلك بوانا ليوسف في
الارض يتبوا
منها وكذلك مكنا ليوسف في الارض يتبوا
منها حيث
يشاء نصيب برحمتنا من نشاء
ولا نضيع اجر
المحسنين ولاجر الاخره خير للذين امنوا
وكانوا
يتقون
وجاء اخوه يوسف فدخلوا عليه فعرفهم وهم له
منكرون ولما
جهزهم بجهازهم قال اتوا
باخ لكم من
ابيكم الا ترون اني اوفي الكيل وانا خير
المنزلين فان لم فان لم تاتوني به فلا كيد
لكم
عندي فلا كيل لكم عندي ولا
تقربون قالوا سنراود عنه اباه وان انا
لفاعلون وقال لفتيانه اجعلوا بضاعتهم في
رحالهم
لعلهم لعلهم
يعرفونها اذا انقلبوا الى اهلهم لعلهم
يرجعون
فلما رجعوا الى ابيهم
قالوه قالوا يا ابانا منع منا الكيل
فارسل فارسل معنا اخانا نكتل وانا له
لحافظون قال هل امنوا قال هل امنه علي قال
هل امنكم عليه
الا الا كما امنتكم على اخيه من قبل فالله
خير
حافظا وهو ارحم
الراحمين
فلما فتحوا متاعهم وجدوا بضاعتهم ردت
اليهم
ولما فتحوا متاعهم وجدوا بضاعتهم ردت
اليهم قالوا يا ابانا ما نبغي هذه بضاعتنا
ردت
الينا ونمير اهلنا ونحفظ اخانا ونزداد كيل
بعير ذلك
كيل
يسير قال لن ارسله معكم حتى تاتوني موثقا
من الله لتات نني به حتى حتى تؤ تون
موثقا من الله لتات نني به
الا الا ان يحاط بكم فلما اتوه موثقهم قال
الله على ما نقول
وكيل وقال يا بني لا تدخلوا من
باب واحد
وادخلوا
وادخلوا من ابواب
متفرقه وما اغني عنكم من الله من
شيء ان الحكم الا لله عليه
توكلت عليه توكلت وعليه
فليتوكل
المتوكلون
ولما دخلوا من حيث امرهم
ابوهم ما كان يغني
عنهم من الله من شيء
الا الا
حاجه في نفس يعقوب
قضاها
وانه لذو علم لما
علمناه
ولكن ان اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا ال
ضالين
امين
ولما دخلوا على يوسف اوى اليه
اخاه قال
اني انا اخوك فلا تبتئس بما كانوا
يعملون فلما
جهزهم ب جهازهم جعل السقايه في رحل
اخيه ثم اذن مؤذن ايتها العير انكم
لسارقون قالوا واقبلوا عليهم ماذا
تفقدون قالوا نفقد صواع الملك ولمن جاء به
حمل بعير
وانا به
زعيم قالوا ت الله لقد علمتم ما جئنا
لنفسد في الارض وما كنا
سارقين قالوا فما
جزاؤه ان كنتم
كاذبين قالوا
جزاؤه من وجد في رحله ف
وجزاؤه كذلك نجزي
الظالمين فبدا باوعيتهم قبل
وعاء
اخيه ثم استخرجها من وعاء
اخيه كذلك كدنا
ليوسف كذلك كدنا ليوسف ما كان ليا خذ اخاه
في دين الملك
الا الا ان
يشاء
الله نرفع
درجات من
نشا وفوق كل ذي علم
عليم الله
اكبر
سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام
السلام عليكم رحمه
الله السلام عليكم رحمه
[Silence]
الله
لامكم
[Silence]
‏comm commit are serv this comm and tak
care
about conc
every about pleas take care of and don't
let
make and
want
‏interac
exp i to
know what sugg the community have us to
that cont the
leveling pr to
makeing sister hing that you listening
to my requ again let me repeat what
asking
‏man and so
something us
make
and for
imp
‏the that is little bassing and feel the
bur of that i just want to ask you to
help me put something in
place
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قالوا ان يسرق فقد سرق اخ له من قبل
اسرها يوسف في نفسها في نفسه ولم يبدها
لهم قال انتم شر
مكانا والله
عليم والله اعلم بما
تصفون والله اعلم بما
تصفون ولما رجعوا الى ابيهم قالوا يا
ابانا و يا ايها العزيز ان له ابا شيخا
كبيرا فخذ احدنا مكانه انا
نراك فخذ احدنا مكانه انا نراك من
المحسنين قال معاذ الله ان ناخذ الا من
وجدنا متاعنا عنده
انا اذا
لظالمون فلما استياسوا منه خلصوا
نجيا قال كبيرهم الم تعلموا ان اباكم قد
اخذ عليكم موثقا من
الله ومن قبل ما فرضتم في يوسف فلن ابرح
الارض حتى ياذن لي ابي او يحكم الله لي
وهو خير
الحاكمين ارجعوا الى ابيكم فقولوا يا
ابانا ان ابنك
سرق وما شهدنا الا بما علمنا وما كنا
للغيب
حافظين واسال القريه التي كنا فيها والعير
التي اقبلنا فيها
وانا
لصادقون قال بل سولت لكم
انفسكم
امرا
فصبر
جميل فصبر جميل عسى الله ان
ياتيني بهم جميعا ان انه هو العليم
الحكيم وتولى عنهم وقال يا اسفى على يوسف
وابيضت عيناه من الحزن فهو كظيم قالوا ت
الله تذكر يوسف حتى تكون
حرضا حت قالو ت الله تفت تذكر يوس
حتى تكون حرضا حتى تكون حرضا او تكون من
الهالكين قال
انما اشكو بثي
وحزني الى
الله واعلم من الله ما لا
تعلمون وقال يا يا بني اذهبوا فتحسسوا من
يوسف
واخيه ولا تياسوا من روح الله انه لا يياس
من روح الله الا القوم
الكافرون فلما دخلوا عليه قالوا يا ايها
العزيز مسنا واهلنا الضر وجئنا
ببضاعه
مزجاه فاوف
الكيل فاوف لنا الكيل وتصدق
علينا
ان الله يجزي
المتصدقين قال هل علمتم ما فعلتم بيوسف
واخيه من قبل ان انتم
جاهلون قال هل علمت
ما فعلتم بيوسف واخيه اذ انتم
جاهلون قالوا
اانك لانت يوسف قال انا يوسف وهذا
اخيه قد
من الله
علينا انه من يتق ويصبر فان
الله فان ان الله لا يضيع اجر
المحسنين قالوا ت الله لقد اثرك الله
علينا وان كنا لخاطئين
قال لا تثريب عليكم اليوم يغفر الله لكم
وهو ارحم
الراحمين اذهبوا بقميصي هذا فالقوه على
وجه ابي يات
بصيرا واتوني باهلكم
اجمعين
ولما فصلت العير قال
ابوهم قال ابوهم اني لاجد ريح يوسف لولا
ان
تفندون قالوا ت الله انك لفي ضلالك القديم
فلما ان
جاء البشير القاه على وجهه فارتد
بصيرا قال الم اقل لكم اني اعلم من الله
ما لا
تعلمون قالوا يا ابانا استغفر لنا ذنوبنا
انا كنا
خاطئين
قال سوف استغفر لكم ربي
انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
فلما دخلوا على يوسف
اوى اليه
ابويه فلما دخلوا على يوسف اوى اليه
ابويه و قال ادخلوا مصر ان
شاء الله
امنين ورفع ابويه على العرش وخروا له
سجدا قال يا ابتي هذا تاويل رؤياي من قبل
قد جعلها ربي
حقا وقد احسن بي اذ اخرجني من السجن وجاء
بكم من البدو من
بعد من بعد ان نزغ الشيطان بيني وبين
اخوتي ان ربي لطيف لما
يشاء
انه هو العليم
الحكيم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحم
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين رب قد اتيتني من الملك
وعلمتني من تاويل
الاحاديث فاطر السماوات والارض انت وليي
في الدنيا
والاخره توفني
مسلما
والحقني
بالصالحين ذلك من
انباء الغيب نوحيه اليك وما كنت لديهم اذ
اجمعوا امرهم وهم
يمكرون ومن اكثر الناس ولو حرست
بمؤمنين وما تسالهم عليه من اجر ان هو الا
ذكر
للعالمين وكاي من ايه في السماوات والارض
يمرون
عليها يمرون عليها وهم
معرضون وهم عنها
معرضون وما يؤمن
اكثرهم بالله الا وهم
مشركون افامنوا انت تاتيهم
غاشيه من عذاب الله او تاتيهم الساعه بغته
وهم لا
يشعرون قل هذه سبيلي ادعوا الى
الله ادعو الى الله على بصيره انا ومن
اتبعني وسبحان الله وما انا من
المشركين وما ارسلنا من قبلك الا
رجالا نوحي اليهم من اهل القرى افلم
يسيروا في الارض
فينظروا كيف كان عاقبه الذين كذبوا من
قبل افلم يسيروا في الارض ينظروا كيف كان
عاقبه الذين من قبلهم ولا الدار الاخره
خير للذين اتقوا افلا
تعقلون حتى اذا استيئس الرسل
وظنوا انهم قد
كذبوا
جاءهم نصرنا فنجي من
نشاء ولا يرد باسنا عن القوم
المجرمين لقد كان في قصصهم عبره لاولي
الالباب ما كان حديثا
يفترى ولكن تصديق الذي بين يديه وتفصيل كل
شيء
وهدى ورحمه
لقوم
يؤمنون
الله
ال
م ر تلك ايات الكتاب والذي انزل اليك من
ربك
الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير
عمد
ترونها ثم استوى على العرش وسخر الشمس
والقمر كل يجري لاجل
مسمى يدبر الامر يفصل الايات
لعلكم
بلقاء ربكم
توقنون وهو الذي مد الارض وجعل فيها رواسي
وانهارا ومن كل الثمرات جعل فيها زوجين
اثنين يغشي الليل
النهار ان في ذلك لايات
لقوم
يتفكرون وفي الارض قطع متجاورات
وجنات
وجنات من
اعناب
وزرع
ونخيل
صنوان وغير
صنوان يسقى
بماء
واحد ونفضل بعضها على بعض في الاكل
ان في ذلك
لايات
لقوم
يعقلون الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
استقيموا واستووا ترسوا
واعتدلوا الله اكبرك اللهم
ربنا الصلاه
ياسك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وان تعجب فعجب قولهم ائذا كنا ترابا
اانا لفي خلق
جديد
اولئك الذين كفروا بربهم وا اولئك الاغلال
في
اعناقهم واولئك اصحاب النار هم فيها
خالدون
ويستعجلونك بالسيئه قبل الحسنه وقد خلت من
قبلهم
المثلات وان ربك لذو مغفره للناس على
ظلمهم وان ربك شديد
العقاب ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه
ايه من ربه انما انت منذر ولكل قوم
هاد الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى وما تغيض
الارحام وما
تزداد وكل شيء عنده
بمقدار عالم الغيب والشهاده الكبير
المتعال
سواء
منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر به ومن هو
مستخف ومن هو مستخف بالليل
وسارب
بالنهار له
معقبات من بين يديه ومن خلفه
يحفظونه من امر
الله ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يغيروا
ما
بانفسهم واذا اراد الله
بقوم
سوءا فلا مرد له وما م من دونه
منوال هو الذي يريكم البرق خوفا
وطمعا وينشئ السحاب
الثقال ويسبح الرعد بحمده
والملائكه من
خيفته ويرسل الصواعق فيصيب بها من
يشاء وهم يجادلون في الله وهو شديد
المحال له دعوه الحق والذين يدعون من دونه
لا
يستجيبون لهم بشيء الا لا
يستجيبون لهم بشيء الا كباسط كفيه الى
الماء ليبلغ فاه ليبلغ فاه وما هو
ببالغه وما
دعاء
الكافرين الا في
ضلال ولله يسجد من في السماوات والارض
طوعا
وكرها
وظلالهم بالغدو
والاصال الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر قل من رب السماوات والارض قل
الله قل افات اخذتم من دونه
اولياء لا ي يملكون لانفسهم نفعا ولا ضرا
قل هل يستوي الاعمى
والبصير ام جعلوا لله
شركاء خلقوا كخلقه فتشابه الخلق
عليهم ام هل تستوي الظلمات
والنور ام جعلوا لله
شركاء خلقوا كخلقه فتشا
الخلق
عليهم قل الله خالق كل شيء وهو الواحد
القهار الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ضالين
امين انزل من
السماء
ماء فسالت اوديه بقدرها فاحتمل السيل زبدا
رابيا ومما يوقدون عليه في
النار ومما يوقدون عليه في النار
ابتغاء حليه او متاع زبد مثله كذلك يضرب
الله الحق
والباطل فاما الزبن فيذهب
جفاء واما ما ينفع الناس فيمكث في الارض
كذلك يضرب الله
الامثال للذين استجابوا لربهم
الحسنى والذين لم يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم
ما في الارض جميعا ومثله معه لافتدوا به
اولئك لهم سوء
الحساب
وماواهم
جهنم وبئس
المهاد الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏all
‏before i get started i think i think
this this ‏has been said many times
before and i you andore
you you want me to implement poy where
some comes and takes out i'll
do
that's know those are preparing
all things
and
صلاه
التراوح ان الحمد لله نحمده ونستعين
ونستغفره ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن
سيئات
اعمالنا اللهم صل وسلم وبار ودك محمد وعلى
اله وصحه اجمعين ومن
تبدين
[Silence]
بعد
‏days
[Silence]
‏make
‏my 30 days
cable there differ
‏eding so buying ping some making person
fes
make can money make they food to for
that
time
[Silence]
‏i
‏from
mar second marage when she had a girl
she also named him h as well so you
correct last night i went back andad
that so
that's so first husb two boys from one
was nam and the second marriage
subsequently a girl from the second husb
and named him named her
[Silence]
عن
خض
[Silence]
عن
‏andw
as
girl
mar is the go to mared we have to
ex
[Silence]
‏asb
عليه
[Silence]
اللاسلام
عل
‏i see at
least south asia men are 45 plus
before
[Silence]
حذ
بالذ
something
as
حث رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ض
عنيه
‏went
andin anding
fring
front said
all this
[Silence]
يه
خشه reas things to
you you know i say this all ‏i have
privil i don't pril not growing up in
three different regions in my life i up
in libia i sp time in pakistan and i sp
time in america i've seen the ises that
have ared out of this institution of
marriage the way we have screwed up the
way the scw
up it is
im and we need to
‏having the dis das and
and that's
beauful this is two here thank you there
other there other to bef so we need to
be very mindful be very careful how we
have to adjust our
institution because if we adj what the
other side the
‏and
gener fl ofin all
of
sisteres
‏this
time we of very
blat cursing and
accusing you know saying things to the
non muslims for the treatment of muslims
but how we muslims are treating each
other is as pivotal as that at least a
non muslim kills
me why is a musl oppressing musl for
what reason is there
‏there is
noas iore you and you that if there is
any
عليه
whater a drop in the ocean
lally you know somebody sent me a
message the what are you reading there's
nothing i'm reading i mean i'm just
giving you little bits here and there
there not a book i can read with you
that i can finish in this time
[Silence]
علال
سال
لا اله الله محد رسول
الله اله الله محول الله
اللهه نا اتنا الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عقبر وق عبنم
وقنا ع الممات وكنا ع فتنه مسيح الدجال
ربنا تقبل منا انك السميع العليم وتوب
علينا يا مو تواب الرحيم صلى الله على
محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم
الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين
استقيم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الذين استجابوا لربهم الحسنى والذين
لم يستجيبوا له لو ان لهم ما في الارض
جميعا ومثله معه لافتدوا به
اولئك لهم سوء الحساب وماواهم
جهنم وبئس
المهاد افمن يعلم انما انزل اليك من ربك
الحق كمن هو اعمى انما يتذكر اولو
الالباب الذين يوفون بعهد الله ولا
ينقضون
الميثاق والذين يصلون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ويخشون ربهم ويخافون
سوء
الحساب والذين صبروا
ابتغاء وجه ربهم واقاموا الصلاه وانفقوا
مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه ويدرؤون
بالحسنه السيئه
اولئك لهم عقب
الدار جنات عدن يدخلونها ومن صلح من
ابائهم وازواج م
وذرياتهم
والملائكه يدخلون عليهم من كل
باب سلام عليكم بما صبرتم فنعم عقب
الدار والذين يقطعون ما امر الله به ان
يوصل ويفسدون في الارض
اولئك لهم اللعنه و م
سوء
الدار والذين ينقضون عهد الله من بعد
ميثاقه ويقطعون ما امر الله به ان يوصل
ويفسدون في الارض ويفسدون في الارض
اولئك لهم اللعنه ولهم
سوء
الدار الله يبسط الرزق لمن يشاء ويقدر
وفرحوا بالحياه الدنيا وما الحياه الدنيا
في الاخره الا
متاع ويقول الذين كفروا لولا انزل عليه
ايه من ربه قل ان الله يضل من
يشاء ويهدي اليه من اناب
الذين امنوا
وتطمئن قلوبهم بذكر الله الا بذكر الله
تطمئن
القلوب الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات طوبى
لهم وحسن
ماب كذلك ارسلناك في
اممه قد خلت من قبلها امم لتتلو عليه
الذي اوحينا
اليك لتتلو عليهم الذي اوحينا اليك وهم
يكفرون
بالرحمن قل هو ربي لا اله الا هو عليه
توكلت واليه
متاب ولو ان قرانا سيرت به الجبال او قطعت
به الارض او كلم به الموتى بل لله الامر
جميعا افلم يياس الذين امنوا ان لو
يشاء الله لهدى الناس
جميعا ولا يزال الذين كفروا تصيبهم بما
صنعوا قارعه او تحل قريبا من
دارهم او تحل قريبا من دارهم حتى ياتي وعد
الله ان الله لا يخلف
الميعاد ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك فامليت
للذين كفروا ثم اخذتهم فكيف كان
عقاب افمن هو
قائم على كل نفس بما كسبت وجعلوا لله
شركاء قل
سموهم ام تنبئونه بما لا يعلم في الارض ام
بظاهر من
القول بل زين للذين كفروا مكرهم وصدوا عن
السبيل ومن يضلل الله فما له من
هاد لهم
عذاب في الحياه الدنيا ولعذاب
اخره اشق وما لهم من الله من
واق الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير الم المغضوب عليهمم ولا
الضالين
امين مثل الجنه التي وعد المتقون تجري من
تحتها الانهار اكلها
دائم
وظلها تلك عقب الذين اتقوا وعقب كفرين
النار والذين اتيناهم الكتاب يفرحون بما
انزل اليك ومن الاحزاب من ينكر بعضه قل
انما امرت ان اعبد الله ولا اشرك به اليه
ادعو واليه
ماب وكذلك
انزلناه حكما عربيا و ان اتبعت
اهواءهم بعد ما
جاءك من العلم ما لك من الله من ولي ولا
واق ولقد ارسلنا رسلا من قبلك وجعلنا لهم
ازواجا وذريه وما كان لرسول ان ياتي بايه
الا باذن الله لكل اجل
كتاب يمحو الله ما
يشاء ويثبت وعنده ام
الكتاب واما نرينك بعض الذي نعدهم او
نتوفينك
فانما عليك البلاغ وعلينا
الحساب اولم يروا انا ناتي الارض ينقصها
من
اطرافها والله يحكم لا معقب لحكمه وهو
سريع
الحساب وقد مكر الذين من قبلهم فلله المكر
جميعا يعلم ما تكسب كل نفس وسيعلم الكفار
لمن عقب
الدار ويقول الذين كفروا لست
مرسلا قل كفى بالله شهيدا بيني وبينكم ومن
عنده علم
الكتاب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الم ر كتاب
انزلناه اليك لتخرج الناس من الظلمات الى
النور باذن رب هم الى صراط العزيز
الحميد الله الذي له ما في السماوات وما
في الارض وويل للكافرين من عذاب
شديد الذين يستحبون الحياه الدنيا على
الاخره ويصدون عن سبيل الله
ويبغونها عوجا
اولئك في ضلال
بعيد وما ارسلنا من رسول الا بلسان قومه
ليبين لهم فيضل الله من
يشاء ويهدي من
يشاء وهو العزيز
الحكيم ولقد ارسلنا موسى باياتنا ان اخرج
قومك من الظلمات الى النور وذكرهم بايام
الله ان في ذلك لايات لكل صبار
شكور واذ قال موسى لقومه اذكروا نعمه الله
عليكم اذ
انجاكم من ال
فرعون اذ
انجاكم من ال فرعون يسومونكم
سوء عذاب ويذبحون
ابناءكم ويذبحون
ابناءكم
ويستحيون
نساءكم وفي ذلكم
بلاء من ربكم
عظيم واذ تاذن ربكم لئن شكرتم لازيدنكم
ولئن كفرتم ان عذابي
لشديد وقال موسى ان تكفروا انتم ومن في
الارض جميعا فان الله لغني
حميد الم ياتكم نبا الذين من قبلكم قوم
نوح وعاد
وثمود والذين من بعدهم لا يعلمهم الا الله
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات فردوا ايديهم في
افواههم
وقالوا وقالوا انا كفرنا بما ارسلتم به
وانا لفي شك مما تدعونا اليه
مريب الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله
استقيم الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ين
امين قالت رسلهم افي الله شك فاطر
السماوات والارض يدعوكم ليغفر لكم من
ذنوبكم ويؤخركم الى اجل
مسمى قالوا ان انتم الا بشر مثلنا تريدون
ان تصدونا عما كان يعبد
اباؤنا فاتونا
بسلطان
مبين قالت لهم رسلهم ان نحن الا بشر مثلكم
وما كان الله ان نحن الا بشر مثلكم ولكن
الله يمن على من
يشاء من عباده وما كان لنا ان ناتيكم
بسلطان الا باذن الله وعلى الله
فليتوكل
المؤمنون وما لنا الا نتوكل على الله وقد
هدانا سبلنا
ولنصبرن على ما اذيتمونا
وعلى الله
فليتوكل الم
وكلون وقال الذين كفروا لرسلهم
لنخرجنكم من ارضنا او لتعودن في ملتنا
فاوحى اليهم ربهم فاوحى اليهم ربهم
لنهلكن
الظالمين ولنسكننكم
الارض من بعدهم ذلك لمن خاف مقامي و ف
وعيد
واستفتحوا وخاب كل جبار
عنيد من
ورائه جهنم ويسقى من
ماء
صديد يتجرعه ولا يكاد يسيغه وياتيه الموت
من كل مكان وما هو بميت ومن
ورائه عذاب
غليظ
وقا مثل الذين كفروا بربهم مثل الذين
كفروا
بربهم اعمالهم كرماد اشتدت به الريح في
يوم عاصف لا يقدرون
مما كسبوا على شيء ذلك هو الضلال
البعيد الم تر ان الله خلق السماوات
والارض بالحق ان يشاء يذهبكم ويات بخلق
جديد وما ذلك على الله
بعزيز وبرزوا لله جميعا فقال
الضعفاء للذين استكبروا انا كنا لكم تبعا
انا كنا لكم تبعا فهل انتم مغنون عنا من
عذاب الله من
شيء قالوا لو هدانا الله لهديناكم
سواء علينا اجزعنا ام صبرنا ما لنا من
محيص وقال الشيطان لما قضي الامر ان الله
وعدكم وعد الحق ووعدتكم فاخلفتكم
ووعدتكم فاخلفتكم وما كان لي عليكم من
سلطان الا ان دعوتكم فاستجبتم لي فلا
تلوموني ولوموا
انفسكم ما انا بمصرخكم وما انتم
بمصرخي ما انا بمصرخكم وما انتم بمصرخي
اني كفرت بما اشركتموني من قبل ان
الظالمين لهم عذاب اليم وادخل الذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار خالدين
فيها خالدين فيها باذن لربهم تحيتهم فيها
سلام الم تر كيف ضرب الله مثلا كلمه طيبه
كشجره طيبه اصلها ثابت وفرعها في
السماء تؤتي اكلها كل حين باذن ربها ويضرب
الله الامثال
لل الناس لعلهم
يتذكرون ومثل كلمه
خبيثه كشجره خبيثه اجتثت من فوق الارض ما
لها من
قرار يثبت الله الذين امنوا بالقول الثابت
في الحياه الدنيا وفي
الاخره ويضل الله
الظالمين
ويفعل الله ما
يشاء الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
الم تر الى الذين بدلوا نعمه الله كفرا
واحلوا قومهم دار
البوار جهنم يصلونها وبئس
القرار وجعلوا لله اندادا ليضلوا عن سبيله
قل تمتعوا فان مصيركم الى
النار
قل لعبادي الذين امنوا يقيموا الصلاه
وينفقوا مما رزقناهم سرا
وعلانيه من قبل ان ياتي يوم لا بيع فيه
ولا
خلال الله الذي خلق السماوات والارض وانزل
من
السماء
ماء
فاخرج به من الثمرات رزقا لكم وسخر لكم
الفلك لتجري في البحر بامره وسخر لكم
الانهار وسخر لكم الشمس والقمر
دائبين وسخر لكم الليل
والنهار
واتاكم من كل ما سالت
وان تعدوا نعمه الله لا
تحصوها ان
الانسان
لظلوم
كفار واذ قال ابراهيم رب اجعل هذا البلد
امنا وارزق واجنبني وبني ان نعبد
الاصنام رب انهن اضللن كثيرا من الناس فمن
تبعني
فانه مني ومن عصاني فانك غفور
الرحيم ربنا اني اسكنت من ذريتي بواد غير
ذي زرع عند بيتك المحرم ربنا ليقيموا
الصلاه فجعل افئده من الناس تهوي اليهم
وارزقهم من ثمرات لعلهم
يشكرون ربنا انك تعلم ما نخفي وما نعلن
وما يخفى على الله من شيء في الارض ولا في
السماء الحمد لله الذي وهب لي على الكبر
اسماعيل واسحاق
ان ربي لسميع
الدعاء رب اجعلني مقيم الصلاه ومن ذريتي
ربنا وتقبل
دعاء ربنا اغفر لي ولوالدي
وللمؤمنين يوم يقوم
الحساب ولا تحسبن الله غافلا عما يعمل
الظالمون انما يؤخرهم ليوم تشخص فيه
الابصار مهطعين مقنعي رؤوسهم لا يرتد
اليهم طرفهم وافئدتهم
هوا وانذر الناس يوم ياتيهم
العذاب فيقول الذين ظلموا ربنا اخرنا الى
اجل قريب نجب دعوتك ونتبع الرسل اولم
تكونوا اقسمتم من قبل ما لكم من
زوال وسكنتم في مساكن الذين ظلموا انفسهم
وتبين لكم كيف فعلنا بهم وضربنا لكم
الامثال وقد مكروا مكرهم وعند الله مكرهم
وان كان مكرهم لتزول من من ه
الجبال فلا تحسبن الله مخلف وعده رسله ان
الله عزيز ذو
انتقام يوم تبدل الارض غير الارض
والسماوات
وبرزوا لله الواحد
القهار وترى المجرمين
يومئذ مقرنين في
الاصفاد
سرابيلهم من قطران وتغشى وجوههم
النار ليجزي الله كل
نفس ما كسبت ان الله سريع
الحساب هذا بلاغ للناس ولينذروا به
وليعلموا ان انما هو
اله
واحد وليعلموا انما هو اله واحد وليذكر
اولو
الالباب الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله استغفر الله العظيم استغفر الله
استقيم اعتدلوا استووا صلاه الوتر ان شاء
الله ودون ركعه ريت وثنا سجود وثنا
تشهد الله اكبر
سبحانك الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك
الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى والذي قدر
فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء ان
احوى سنقرئك فلا
تنسى الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان
نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى
ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
صلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا
والاخره خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف
ابراهيم
وموسى الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذ
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل
يا ايها
الكافرون
لا اعبد ما
تعبدون
ولا
انتم عابدون ما اعبد
ولا انا
عابد ما
عبدتم
ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد لكم دينكم ولي
دين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد لم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام
عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
ا